اذا شكرا لخالد مشاهدينا اهلا بكم انا
ميسون عزام احييكم ونستكمل معكم هذه
التغطيه على مدار الساحه حول السودان هدنه
يبدو انها ستتكمل اخر اربع ساعات متبقيه
لها بغض النظر عن ما اذا كان الفرقاء
سيعلنون عن تمديدها ام لا ترى فاصله اوفوا
بوعود الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار بالرغم
من سماع دول الانفجارات والرصاص بين الحين
والاخر طبعا اخرها ما نشاهده على العواجل
من عوده لاطلاق النار وذلك في شارع المطار
بالقرب من القياده العامه على كل قائد
الجيش والدعم السريع نقلات جزء من صراعهما
الى المنابر الاعلاميه بعد ان توعد
باستكمال الاشتباكات حتى النهايه اما عن
شكل تلك النهايه فتبدو ملامحها قاسيه على
السودان وعلى السودانيين الذين يعانون منذ
سته ايام من تبعات صراع لا ناقه لهم فيها
ولا جمل
[موسيقى]
وعن اعداد الضحايا قالت منظمه الصحه
العالميه انها رصدت مقتل
330 شخصا واصابه ثلاثه الاف ومئتين اخرين
جراء الاشتباكات في السودان الصحه
العالميه دعت جميع الاطراف في السودان
لهدنه انسانيه لسماح للمواطنين بالحصول
على الرعايه الطبيه كما اكدت المنظمه انها
ستجلب المزيد من التجهيزات الطبيه لدى
السماحي بذلك مشيره الى النقص الحاد في
امدادات المياه والوقود في المنشات الصحيه
بالسودان كما اضافت المنظمه ان عشرين مشفا
خرجوا من الخدمه بسبب الهجمات او نقص
الموارد
[موسيقى]
فيما يتعلق بالسيطره على الارض هناك مشاهد
تتداوله ومواقع التواصل لحظات سيطره
الفرقه الثانيه مشات في الجيش السوداني
على عربات تتبع عناصر قوات الدعم السريع
بولايه القضارف دعونا نتابع
الفرقه الثانيه
هذه عربات قوات الدعم السريع بولايه
القضارف الفرقه الثانيه
من العربات
[موسيقى]
الفرقه الثانيه
القوات المسلحه وحول حركه المواطنين اظهرت
مقاطع فيديو ايضا على منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي حركه المسافرين في جنوب الخرطوم
افادت مصادر اعلاميه بمغادره الالاف من
المواطنين للعاصمه السودانيه طبعا بسبب
تدهور الوضع الامني
[موسيقى]
هذا وبحث وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان ونظيره البريطانيه جيمس
كليفري تطورات الاوضاع في السودان وذلك
خلال اتصال هاتفي الوزيران دعا الى وقف
اطلاق النار والتصعيد العسكري وانهاء
العنف وحمايه المدنيين وتوفير الممرات
الامنه للعمليات الانسانيه
المزيد معنا من جنوب الخرطوم الصحفي مدثر
محمد احمد اهلا بك
سيدي بدايه هل لك ان تعطينا فكره عما يحدث
على الارض اخر المعلومات التي تتحدث تقول
بانه هناك عوده للاشتباكات في شارع المطار
بالقرب من مقر القياده العامه هل لديك
معلومات او تفاصيل متى واين تخترق هذه
الهدنه
منطقه منطقه القياده العامه وما جاورها
ومحيطها هذه لم تهدا منذ بدء تريان الهدنه
وحتى الان هناك اشتباكات متقطعه بين
والاخرى وهذا نات عن طبيعه حركه حركه
القوات
واحدا من شروط هذه الهدنه هو عدم عدم عدم
اتخاذ مواقع جديده للقوات عدم التنوع من
من مكان الى مكان ولذلك
هل هناك تبادل
مستمره بين الجانبين في منطقه او محيط
القياده العامه في وسط الخرطوم كذلك كانت
هناك اشتباكات في منطقه
في منطقه
اليوم او فجر اليوم ولكن ضجيله هذا اليوم
لم نرشد اي اشتباكات في منطقه على الاقل
في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم ومنطقه شرق النيل
هنا في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم من ناحيه شرق
النيل لم تكن هناك اي اشتباكات لم تسمع
الينا الى مسامعنا اييي من اشتباكات في
هذه المنطقه
وفي ظل ما ذكرته من اشتباكات متقطعه
ومحصوره ربما اذا مصحه تعبير في مناطق
بعينها كيف هي حركه المواطنين وان كانت هي
هدنه انسانيه هل لبت هذا الطلب
نعم الهدنه الانسانيه بكل تاكيد استغلها
المحتاجين او الذين
بداوا ونشطوا الامس في استغلال هذه الهدنه
بتلبيه الاحتياجات الانسانيه للمرضى الذين
يودون الخروج من مناطق الاشتباكات كانت
هناك نداءات منذ مساء امس على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
لمساعده الذين انقطعت بهم السبل في منطقه
الاشتباكات للخروج ولكن
يعني تمت هذه بعمليه تمت منذ صباح اليوم
هناك العديد من الذين تمكنوا من الخروج من
منطقه الاشتباكات هناك ايضا عدد من الذين
يقتلون في مناطق ام درمان ومناطق بحري
ومناطق شرق النيل تمكنوا من من الخروج من
ولاده الخرطوم عبر منافذ الولايه التي
تخرج الى الولايات القريبه من الخرطوم
هناك حركه سفر منذ صباحها الان اليوم عبر
الطرق البريه الرابطه بين ولايه الخرطوم
والولايات الاخرى
في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم هذه في منطقه كوبري
شوبا ومن الناحيه الشرقيه ومن الناحيه
الغربيه الكبرى تحولت الى سوق كبير هذا
بخلاف الاسواق الاخرى في منطقه جبل اولياء
في جنوب الخرطوم من ناحيه غرب الغرب ولايه
الخرطوم ايضا تحولت الى الى مواقف كبيره
لعمليات العمليات الترحيل للولايات الاخرى
سنكمل الحديث ولكن هناك خبر الان وردنا
الدعم السريع يدعو الى تمديد الهدنه
الحاليه لتشمل عيد الفطر نتمنى يعني ان
تطبق هذه الهدنه ايضا ودون ان يكون هناك
اشتباكات متقطعه على كل
نامل في ذلك ومن خلال متابعتك ما بين
الهدنه الاولى التي رفضت الهدنه الثانيه
التي طبقت ولكنها كانت هشه وهذه الهدنه هل
تتلمسون الان من خلال هذه الدعوه لكي تشمل
عيد الفطر اي امال بانه الوضع يتحسن فيما
يتعلق بامكانيه الوصول ربما الى تسويه ام
انه
مشدات الاعلاميه اذا مصحه تعبير بين
الرجلين ستحول دون اي امل في الوصول الى
حل
هناك هناك
قياده الطرفين للوصول الى حل او الى
الحوار او الى الجلوس الى الحوار وتوقف
هذه الحرب هذه ظلت تطلق من كافه
الدول الشقيقه والصديقه والمجتمع الدولي
والمنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه بان يجب ان
تتوقف هذه الحرب والجلوس للحوار مره اخرى
كانت هناك الامان معلقه على الدعوه التي
اطلقها الامين العام بجامعه الدول العربيه
منذ امس في ان تكون هناك هدنه خلال عطله
عيد الفطره المبارك يتوفى فيها اطلاق
النار حتى يستطيع يستطيع المواطنون يعني
الاحتفال بعيد الفطر
ويبدو ان هناك اتجاه للقبول بهذه الدعوه
السريع قبل ذلك بحسب التصريحات التي
وردتنا ولكن سؤال يتعلق بما يحدث على
الارض مقارنه ما نسمع من تصريحات اعلاميه
هل ما يحدث على الارض يعكس بالفعل ما نسمع
من الرجلين او انه الميدان يتحدث بطريقه
مختلفه كليا
لا تستطيع ان تحكم بشكل دقيق على ما يحدث
في الشارع
مقارنه بما يتحدث به الرجل
بكل تاكيد في زمن الهدنه هناك لا يفيد
المقارنه بينها وبين
ايام الاشتباكات الاولى التي كان فيها
الاشتباكات عني
فه برغم انها مخترقه من يعني من هنا وهناك
الا انها ليست هناك مقارنه بينها وبين
ايام الاشتباكات
رقعه المواجهات رقعه الاشتباكات تكون على
كافه المحاور خلال الاشتباك اما في في في
زمن الهدنه فان الاشتباكات تكون محدوده وم
تقطع يعني في مناطق محدوده لا تذكر بحجم
رقعه ولايه الخرطوم او بحسب رقعه
العاصمه التي فيها هذه الاحداث نعم كان
هناك اتهامات للدعم السريع بانها قواتها
تقوم بعمليات نهب وغيره واعتداءات ايضا
كيف هو الوضع في الخرطوم الى اي حد بعيدا
عن الاشتباكات
كاشتباكات مباشره بالسلاح الى اي حد هناك
نوع من الامن ام انه لا هناك فوضى تحت
الارض هناك من يستغل هذه الحرب ويتحرك على
الارض ان كان من الطرفين او من جهات اخرى
نعم بكل تاكيد نحن نرفض في في في العديد
من الاحاديث التي تدور في في الاحياء
المختلفه التي
يتواجد بها عناصر او قوات الدعم السريع
هناك هذه الاحداث او هذه الاحاديث التي
تتحدث عن عمليات نعم من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع او اي من القوات
هناك من يتحدث عن وجود عمليات سلف هناك من
تحدثوا لنا بالامس
تحباشره عن افراد قوات الدعم السريه
ذهبت الى عدد من المناطق
ولم تقم باي عمليات نحن وانما قامت بشراء
احتياجاتها عن طريق الاموال ولكن ايضا
هناك بعض الذين تحدثوا عن ان قوات الدعم
السريع وتم تصوير هناك بعض الصور التي
بوست عن عمليه اقتحام لبعض هؤلاء الجنود
لمحال تجاريه ومحال خاصه وتمت عمليات نحب
هناك احاديث عن من يتحدثون خلال الذين
الذين يخرجون في
دولابتكازات من المسائيه تحدثوا عن ان
هناك عمليات تفتيش وعمليات سلبي الذين
يغادرون ولايه الخرطوم كل هذه الاحاديث
يعني تحدث ولكن هي لا تخرج من باب الحرب
الاعلاميه وباب الحرب النفسيه خلال
الازمات التي تنظر حتى الان
للخسائر
الماديه طبعا على الارض الا في بعض
المناطق ابقى معي لانه الزميل نزار بقداوي
مراسل العربيه والثق جزء من الدمار الذي
لحق بالقاعده الجويه العسكريه التابعه
لمطار مروي دعنا نتابع واعود اليك الجديد
باننا الان داخل هذا المطار وداخل القاعده
العسكريه العملياتيه في مدينه مروي هذا هو
برج المراقبه الرئيس للقاعده وللمطار هذا
البرج الذي كنا يوم امس في هذه النقطه وقد
عاكسنا حجم الضرر الذي لحق به
هذه الاجهزه اكيزه التواصل والاتصال
يبدو انها مدمره بالكامل
واستقبال الطائرات
عبر اجهزه الرادر محمد بالنسبه
هنا هذه الصور لهذه الاجهزه اللاسلكيه
يبدو انها خارج الخدمه مع من الان
كالنتيجه اشتباكات حصلت في هذه المواقع ام
تدمير للعناصر الدعم السريع ربما التي
كانت موجوده قبل انسحابها ماذا يقول
هو مؤكد خالد
المطروحه الان بان الاشتباكات كانت عنيفه
كل ما يحدث من ضرر هو نتيجه لهذا
الاشتباكات نتيجه للقصف العنيف الذي شهدته
هذه المنطقه
هذا ما يمكن ان نؤكد عليه بان الضرر وقع
نتيجه لعمل عسكري كانت هذه المنطقه من
المطار
مسرحا
وكانت ارضيه لكل العمليات العسكريه القصف
المدفعي القصف العنيف
حجم الضرر هذا الدمار الذي لحق بالمطار
لحق بالقاعده لحق بهذا البرج لهذه القاعده
وهذا المطار الذي يمثل احد اهم المطارات
في المنطقه الاقليميه لانه يطل على
الاتجاه الشمالي للسودان على حدود السودان
مع دوله مصر
منهم مباشره يمكن ان يتم التنسيق كما فعل
مسبقا الجيش السوداني مع عدد من جيوش
الدول في المنطقه الاقليميه
ايضا يعتبر هذا المطار بديلا لمطار
الخرطوم الدولي اذا ما حدثت اي متغيرات في
مطار الخرطوم يتم الاستعانه بهذا المطار
طبعا هذه الصور من مراسلنا ولكن الجيش
السوداني بالمقابل نشره مقطع فيديو يظهر
سيطرته على قاعده الشيفرلي في شماليه
غربيه البلاد وهي تعتبر طبعا من اكبر خطوط
الامداد لقوات الدعم السريع نتابع
تم استلام معسكر الشفرليت التابعه لقوات
الدعم السريع بعد ان قاموا هاربين منها تم
استلام عدد خمس عربه لاندك وعدد واحد تنكر
ماء وعدد جاك همر وكميه من الاسلحه
والزخائن
[موسيقى]
من فضله في هذه الساعه
وتم الاستدلال على عدد خمسه عرب كروزر
حريق في مهند للسلاح مهند للسلاح حريق في
الخرطوم اثنين شارع الصناعات شارع
الصناعات
اللي قاعده فوق وما قادر تطلع فلوس قاعده
فوق ما قادره تطلع حريق حريق
حريق من حلبه
[تصفيق]
يا جماعه النداء لاي زول بيعرف اي جهه
مطافي في اي جهه ممكن تيجي تتدخل في الحته
دي الناس المفروض تجي في الحته دي فوق
اطفال قاعدين فوق في العماره والناس
وفي ثلاثه ولا اكتر من اربع عمارات موجوده
تحت لبعض
[تصفيق]
نداء استغاثه يا جماعه في اكتر من اربع
عمارات جنب بعض يفوز قاعده فوق
اذا مشاهدينا هذه صور المساء ولكن ماذا عن
الوضع الان في هذه اللحظات ننقل لكم هذه
الصور حصريه للعربيه طبعا للعاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم دخان يتصاعد على مقربه
من القياده العامه كان هناك انباء تتحدث
طبعا عن ان هناك اشتباكات قد عادت في شارع
المطار القريب من تلك المنطقه طبعا الهدوء
نسبه في العاصمه السودانيه منذ بدا هذه
الهدنه ثلاث ساعات ونصف الساعه على موعد
انتهائها ولكن قبل قليل اعلنا وشاهدنا على
العواجل ان الدعم السريع قد وافق على
تمديد الهدنه لتشمل ايام عيد الفطر كامله
ننتظر لنستمع الى ردود الفعل طبعا نستمع
الى هذه الطلقات الناريه كل من تحدثنا
معهم وان اكدوا ان هذه الهدنه صامده اكثر
من الهدنه الماضيه الا ان ذلك لا يمنع من
اشتباكات متقطعه دعونا نستمع
اذا مشاهدينا استمعنا الى بعض الطلقات
الناريه وهذا ما اكده العديد من المتابعين
والمتواجدين في داخل العاصمه السودانيه
اشتباكات ولكنها متقطعه وفي معظمها قرب
القياده العامه على كل دعونا نستمع الى
راي رئيس التحرير صحيفه التغيير رشا عوض
وتنضم الينا الان مباشره من الخرطوم
واسمحيلي ان ابدا ان كان لديك اي معلومات
بدايه عما يحدث على الارض وهذه الطلقات
الناريه التي نستمع اليها اشتباكات مباشره
اطلاق نار عشوائي ام ماذا
التحيه لك والتحيه للمشاهدين الكرام
اهلا
عفوا
لا احد يستطيع على وجه الدقه ما الذي يجري
من الذي يطلق النيران
ولكن اعتدنا انه بعد كل اعلان عن هدنه
تكون هناك
اختراقات لهذه الهدنه من هذا الطرف او ذاك
الثابت في هذا الامر
ان هذه الحرب الان
اكتسبت منطقها الخاص
الذي سيحدد مالاتها لا ندري متى تنتهي متى
تتوقف رغم اننا نتمنى ان تتوقف اليوم قبل
الغد طيب نتمنى ان تنجح الهدنه في خدمه
الاهداف الانسانيه الملحه لا شك ان الكل
يتمنى ذلك ولا احد يعلم الى اين تتجه
الامور ولكن يمكن تقييم الوضع ومقارنه ما
حدث بالايام السته الماضيه وما يحدث الان
رغم الطلقات الناريه هل تشعرين ان هناك
نوع من التقدم هل عندما نتحدث عن هدنه
وهنا تعود الطلقات الناريه كما نشاهد
ونستمع مشاهدينا خلال هذه الصور المباشره
التي ننقلها لكم حصريا من العربيه من قلب
العاصمه الخرطوم هل تشعرين بان هناك نوع
من التقدم خاصه انها ستشمل ايام العيد ولا
نتحدث الان عن ليله واحده او ليلتين
يعني لا
استطيع الذي ينتشر في اماكن متفرقه على
خلفيه هذه الهدنه ولكن المشهد المؤلم ان
سكان هذه المدينه المنقوبه الان يتحول الى
نازحين
يصرون الى الولايات ليس بهدف قضاء عطله
العيد بين اقاربهم كما كان الحارس الساب
ق والقتال يعني شبح الحرب بكل تداعياتها
المؤلمه يقابده السودانيون الان هناك
هنا في
الى النزوح
تعرضوا للاطلاق الرصاص او تعرضوا للرصاص
الطائش فحتى طرق النزوح ليست امنه تماما
اسال الله السلامه لجميع الناجين من هذه
المحرق وخاصه انه تصريحات ليست بالمبشره
ما بين الرجلين
ما بين البرهان الذي يؤكد انه الحل هو
بهزيمه قوات حماتي وما بين حماه الذي يؤكد
بانه الحل هو بتقديم البرهان للمحاكمه
بمعنى وكانه ليس هناك من طريق نحو الحل
والسؤال هنا هل نحن نتحدث عن صراع رجلين
صراع القياده ام انه لازلنا نتحدث عن صراع
مؤسسات اذا مصحه التعبير ما بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
ولا صراع رجلين ولا صراع مؤسساتي هو صراع
فلول النظام البائد الذين يختطفون اراده
الجيش السوداني
ويتخفون تحت مظله الجيش السوداني للعوده
الى السلطه مجددا يحاربون الدعم السريع
لان الدعم السريع هو الاخر له اقنعه في
السلطه وهم الان هذا الفصيل والدعم السريع
في معركه تكسير عظام على رؤوس الابرياء
وعلى رؤوس النساء والاطفال وهذا امر مؤسف
جدا وهذا امر يدل الى اي مدى وقع السودان
في قبضه قيادات غير مسؤوله وفاقده للضمير
وفاقده للمسؤوليه طيب ابقى ما ابقي معي يا
سيدتي معي من الخرطوم المحلل السياسي
الباشا محمد طبيق انضم اليه الان اهلا بك
بدايه دعنا نتحدث عن الدعم السريع واعلانه
قبول لماذا يقبل بهذه الهدنه رغم اننا
نشاهد رغم الهدوء النسبي الذي تلمسناه على
الاقل في هذه الهدنه الا ان الاشتباكات لا
زالت مستمره على الارض وحتى على المستوى
الاعلامي ما بين الرجلين
الدعم السريع بهذه الهدنه هو التزام
اخلاقي
للمناداه المحليه والاقليميه والدوليه
يعني
بهذه الهدنه لدواعي انسانيه انه كون طرف
من الاطراف يعلن التزامه بهذه الهدنه فهذا
التزام اخلاقي وهذه استجابه وحسن
يعني
لمعالجه بعض
الاوضاعليه الحرجه ولخروج بعض العالقين
الذين ما زالوا يعني بعض المواقع يعني
التي قريبه من المواقع الاجتماع ومن ثم
ماذا الباشا محمد
ومن ثم ماذا ما بعد هذه الهدنه ماذا
والله نتمنى نتمنى ان تستمر
هذه الايام نعيد نحن الان في اليوم لقد
يكون اليوم الاخير من شهر رمضان المبارك
والان الهدنه قد تنتهي الى الساعه 6:00
مساء التي حدثت له هناك
لكن يعني طلب من الاطراف يلتزم بهذه
الهدنه انه هذا عمل ايجابي ونتمنى ان
تستمر المناسبات وتستمر تدخلات الدوليه من
اجل ايقاف هذه الحرب النعيله والهكر يعني
تحكيم صوت العقل والرجوع الى
التفاوضات طرق للحل يعني لانه اصلا
المديريه ليست وتمسك بعض الاطراف بالقتاله
انه هو انسداد انسداد للافق وعدم يعني
مراعاه
الظروف الايطاليه التي يمر بها الشعب
السوداني اذا استمرت هذه هذه المعارك
واستمر القتال قد تلقى ابواب اخرى وقد
تكون هنالك تدخلات دوليه من بعض يعني بعض
الاطراف في هذه الحرب لان السودان الان
تتقاطع فيه الدوليه والمصالح الدوليه ونحن
نخشى ان توزع
يعني السودان صحيه
وان تصفيه حسابات المحاور الدوليه في
السودان
واحنا الان نريد ايقاف هذه الحرب فورا حتى
لا نشات تفكك الدوله السودانيه
ينزل يعني السودان الى حرب اهليه شامله
لانه الان هنالك
نزول مفتوحي لان هذه الحرب الصغير الى
الولايات وقد تصوير
لتصريحات
لدارفور يمكن ان نضيفها الى المخاطر الان
التي طرات على المشهد سانتقل اليها بعد
قليل ولكن عندي سؤال ذكرت انه تمسك بعض
الاطراف بمواقفها هو الذي يحول دون الوصول
الى حل بحسب التصريحات وعلى الاقل دعنا
ناخذ اخر التصريحات التي طرحت اعلاميا ما
بين البرهان وحمتي حمتي يقول بانه لن
يتوقف ولا يتراجع عن اهدافه وتعهد بتقديم
البرهان للمحاكمه وبالمقابل البرهان قال
بانه المسار الديمقراطي مرهون بهزيمه قوات
حملتي بمعنى اخر ليس هناك من طرف متمسك
واخر غير متمسك يبدو ان الطرفين متمسكان
بمواقفهما اليس كذلك
التمسك بهذه المواقف والاستمرار الاستمرار
في الحرب او يعني الحرز على هذه الحرب انه
الخاسر منه هو الوطن يعني خاطر منه هو
الوطن ونحن الان
تدمير البنيه التحتيه للسودان تدمير
المطارات ونشاهد الان يعني
كثير جدا من الخدمات الان يعني متوقفه
تماما المستشفيات العامه توجد يعني مسجلات
خارجيه على الخدمه هنا امراض مزمنه يعني
هنالك اصحاب يعني القتيله القتيله الكلوي
وامراض السكري والضغط وكثير جدا من
الامراض الامراض المزمنه الان
متمسك متمسك الاطراف واصرار عن الحرب
بالتاكيد سوف يؤدي الى نتيجه يعني مسلمه
ويؤدي الى كثير من
معاناه الشعب السوداني لانه حتى الان ليس
هنالك في الافق الغريب انتصار انتصار الان
فرض على طرف يعني حتى يفرض سيطرته طبيعي
ايقاف الحرب طبعا انا تعليقي كان لانك انت
حضرتك ذكرت انه بعض الاطراف متمسكه وانا
كانت الجمله تعيطي تتعلق بالتصريحات
الاخيره سادخل فيها في التفاصيل واعود
اليك لنضع المشاهد في التفاصيل
الحوار والمواجهه ما بين البرهان وايضا
حميتي اعلاميا عبد الفتاح البرهان عذرا
حمل قوات الدعم السريع التي يقودها محمد
حمدان دقلو الملقب بحمدتي المسؤوليه
الكامله عن اعمال نهب في الخرطوم وايضا في
دارفور البرهان اكد في تصريحات لصحيفه
ان جزءا كبيرا من قوات الدعم السريع خرجت
عن سيطره حمدتي وقال ان الانتقال الى
المسار الديمقراطي مرهون بهزيمه قوات
حمدتي من جهاته وفي تصريحات ايضا
اكد حمدتي ان قواته لن تتراجع عن اهدافها
وتعهد بتقديم البرهان للمحاكمه اوضح انه
منفتح على وقف اعمال العنف لكنه اشار الى
ان البرهان لا يفعل الامر نفسه متهما اياه
بانه ليس مستعدا للانتقال للحكم المدني
طبعا بحسب تعبير حمدتي بالمقابل اتهمت
قوات الدعم السريع الجيش السوداني بمهاجمه
قواتها في ام درمان مشيره الى تمكن الدعم
السريع من التصدي للهجوم على تمركزاتها
غربيه المدينه القوات اضافت اما عناصرها
اسقطت مروحيتين للقوات الجويه السودانيه
كما اكدت على ما وصفته بالتزام قواتها
بالبقاء في مواقعها ووقف اطلاق النار منذ
اعلان الهدنه
[موسيقى]
وعلى كل حول اوضاع المدنيين معنا من
الخرطوم الدكتور منتصر محمد عثمان مدير
الاداره العامه للطوارئ الصحيه ومكافحه
الاوبئه في وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه
السودانيه اهلا بك دكتور ضعنا في صوره
الوضع الانسان والصحه على الارض تفضل
نحن بالنسبه لنا في الوضع زي ما هو واضح
نعمل من الله سبحانه
يكفي البلاد شرب الفتن والبلاء نحن عندنا
تسعه ولايات الشرف ولايه
بصوره اقل الولايات ما فيها تاثير
عندنا حوالي 3,000 و180 تسجيل لجروح وصلت
المستشفيات المراكز الصحيه
بكل الولايات
حواليت 331
وفاه
يكونوا شهداء ربنا يتقبلهم بشهادات في هذا
الشهر الكريم اكثر الولايات المتاثره هي
ولايه الخرطوم
لتسجيل 1922 حتى الان حاله
مجروح وصل للمستشفى
بالاضافه لولايه جنوب دارفور 688
وشمال دارفور
الشماليه وبعد كذا تعدد باقي الولايات
عندي سؤال لانه هل الارقام قلت مستوى
الضغط فيما يتعلق كان بالضحايا او عمليه
الوصول الى من يحتاج الى مساعدات انسانيه
صحيه طبعا هنا نتحدث وتحرك الاطقم الطبيه
اصبح
احسن تحت الهدنه تغير او لا
اختي الكريمه احنا حتى الان نعمل
لضمان في كل الولايات لضمان سريان الخدمات
الصحيه الاساسيه
في مناطق صعب الوصول اليها حتى تم
سحب الكوادر الطبيه والمرضى
بالمستشفى الخرطوم مستشفى الشعب
والمستشفيات الموجوده في وسط الخرطوم
للتاثر بالوضع الامني حتى مع الهدنه دكتور
منتصر اسمح لي حتى مع الهدنه لا يمكن
توفير اي ممرات امنه بتلك المناطق تحديدا
بالنسبه لنا بمناطق هذه حتى الان ما عندنا
اي طريقه للحركه ككادر طبي عندنا مستشفيات
الان تشكو من امدادات قله في امدادات
الوقود نحن ما قادرين نفصلها
رغم التواصل معانا الفنيه لانه الارشده
بوقود لكن الصلاه لكن على العموم بالنسبه
الكلام ده في الوضع في ولايه الخرطوم وسط
ولايه الخرطوم في اجزاء معينه في ولايه
الخرطوم مدينه الخرطوم ومدينه بحري
بالنسبه
احياء الطرفيه والمستشفيات الطرفيه الان
بتعمل
مستشفيات بتعمل بصوره منتظمه
الصحي هنا في ام درمان يتوفر في مناطق
تتوفر الخدمه بتاعه اذا كان رعايه صحيه او
مستشفيات رعايه الثانويه بالذات المناطق
الطرفيه عندما نتحدث عن التجهيزات والحاجه
اليها منظمه الصحه العالميه كانت قالت
بانه ستحاول جلب المزيد من التجهيزات
الطبيه لدى السماح بذلك هل من تواصل من
قبل المنظمات الدوليه معكم وهل يتم
توفير اي تجهيزات او في اي خطط الان وضعت
لتوفيرها او لا
[موسيقى]
الصحه ابتدينا في التوزيع بالنسبه لنا في
الطوارئ الصحيه والولايات في انه توزيع
ضمان توزيع السريان توزيع الادويه
لجزم من المستشفيات العامله الان في
الولايه او في باقي الولايات ولايه شمال
دارفور الان فيها المخزون جيد نشتكي من
الاشكال في ولايه جنوب دارفور الاخوه بنصح
العالميه مشكورين ايضا الان هم همم طلبوا
امداد زياده امداد بالنسبه لهم على اساس
انهم يمدونا نحن اديناهم
ما الذي تحتاجونه وما هي اللائحه التي
قدمت لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
فيها ادويه فيها بنفس الطريقه عندنا
لمده طويله لا يخفى عليكم هي برضه من ضمن
الحوجات وعندنا
للعمل الجراحي هنحتاج لكميات كبيره ونتوقع
ان شاء الله اذا ربنا فرج هذه الغمه برضه
نفس الطريقه نحتاج لك كميه اكبر من العمل
الجراحي لان عندنا حتى الان موجودين ناس
مصابين نحن نعرفهم موجودين وما قادرين
يتحركوا بنفس الطريقه بتفتح افاق انه نحن
نستعيد بصوره اكبر
الموجوده الان برضه من ضمن المنظمات مع
منظمه الصحه العالميه في منظمه اليونسير
منظمه الهلال الهلال الاحمر السوداني
الهلال الاحمر
الخيريه الان كلهم ابدو استعدادهم من
مساعده القلوب بنفس الطريقه
استعداد للمساعده متى محال الوقت حتى ابدا
استجابتي لانه يغير الخطط لانه الامن
للاسف الشديد البنى التحتيه الموجوده في
المستشفيات ابتدينا نفقدها زي ما زي ما
انتم عارفين في مستشفى الشعب عندنا محطه
ما مر عليها ثلاثه شهور من العمل للاسف
الشديد الان هي
دمرت تماما دي بتاثر علينا في العمل
فالنقاط زي هذه اكيد حتحتاج لانه بعد ان
شاء الله وقوف الحرب والكتاب الامر طيب
عندما تتحدث هذه المنظمات عن دعمكم لديها
مخزون داخل السودان ام اننا نتحدث عن
عمليه امداد بريه وبالتالي صعوبات وتاخير
اكثر
على المدى القصير في
مخزون الان موجود داخلي زي ما قلت لك الان
في منظور من ضمن غرفه الطوارئ عندنا
مجموعه امداد والعمل كله
هذا الذي يخص وزاره الصحه في السودان ولكن
اتحدث عن المنظمات الدوليه
في اجتماع واليوم بنفس الطريقه الناس
متابعه
لتسيير العمل في الامدادات اللي هي
المخازن الموجوده بولايه الخرطوم لسحب ما
هو موجود فيه هو توزيعه على المستشفيات
والمراكز العامله وبرضو نفس الطريقه
النقص في جزء من الولايات نتوقع انه اذا
اشتد الامر
وكثره الحالات نستفيد نستعين بولايات
بولايه الجزيره وولايه نهر الليل الان في
حالات وصلت ولايه الجزيره في مخزون من
موجود منظمه الصحه العالميه في البحر
الاحمر ونعمل انه نستفيد منه برضه في
الباقي الولايات في ولايه جنوب دارفور
واولاده
يعني المخزون كافن للتعاطي مع الوضع الان
الداخليا في السودان لا تحتاجون الى امداد
تجهيزات من الخارج عندي سؤال فيما يتعلق
بالتركيز
منه
دكتور منتصر بس عشان
الصوره
بس بس عم بسال سؤال توضح الصوره انت ذكرت
انه في لائحه قدمت لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
تحتاجونها وبالتالي كان سؤالي هل سيتم
مدكم بهذه الاجهزه او ما تحتاجون من
الداخل السوداني والمخزونات الموجوده او
انتم تحتاجون الى اكثر ما هو متوفر في
الداخل السوداني هذا كان سؤالي
اللائحه الموجوده الان هي ما متوفره في
الداخل نحن نحتاجها من الخارج على اساس
انها نضمن بها انه العمل في الخدمات
الصحيه في الفتره القادمه طيب السؤال
الثاني يتعلق بما ذكرته من عمليات
واهتمام بالمصابين لا شك انه بالحياه
العاديه هناك مرضى يحتاجون لعمليات
يحتاجون لادويه يحتاجون لرعايه صحيه
الاولويه الان للمصابين وماذا عن هؤلاء
اختي العزيزه الان انت زي ما عارفه كان
عندنا اشكال اصلا في توفير الدواء للمرضى
بالذات للامراض المزمنه لفتره طويله تم
المعالجه في في الشهور السابقه
لكن الان نحن اكيد حيكون فيها عجز في
الشهور القادمه لانه المخزون الموجود لا
يكفي لانه يسد الرمق لمعالجه كل الحالات
دي من ضمن الاحتياجات الان مع الناس بتعيد
فيها وتطلبها عن طريق
الوزاره وعن طريق المنظمات او طريق الاخوه
السودانيين العاملين بالخارج قد ايه في
امكانيه للتواصل فيما بينكم كاجهزه طبيه
وكوادر
نحن عندنا تواصل الجهات الفنيه المشموله
في العمل لجامع الفنيه اذا كان اللجان
العليا واللي جانا الفنيه كغرفه الطوارئ
الاتحاديه وغرف الطوارئ الالهيه عندنا
تواصل الان بالمنظمات
العامله بالوزارات الاخرى من ضمنها وزاره
الدفاع للعمل على تامين جزء من الامدادات
بالارشا الاخوه
للدفاع المدني ساعدونا في ربط المياه
المراكز الغير ما موجود فيها المياه
وديتنا كثير في انه ننعيش فيه بالذات في
لمرضى غسيل الكلى في انه يتوفر المياه
لمواصله العمل في غسيل الكيلاني من ضمن
الامراض المزمنه اللي احنا بنشتكي منها
ونعمل انه المراكز ما تجي عشان هم
بيحتاجوا للغسيل بالصوره دائما بنفس
الطريقه باقي الامراض وباقي العمليات اللي
احنا بنحتاجها الان الخطه في انه تتوفر في
كل محليه في في ولايه الخرطوم وكل
الولايات الاخرى يتوفر مستشفى مرجعي يقوم
بالمعالجه للحالات المزمنه ويقوم برضه
بالعمليات العمليات البارده
يحتاج انها تكون متواصله لكن
الاشكال الكبير عندنا في عدم سهوله حركه
الكوادر الصحيه والطبيه في المناطق اللي
فيها التاثيرات في الضغط طيب منتصر بس
سؤال الاخير فيما يتعلق بما ذكرته
بالبدايه عن بعض المستشفيات التي خرجت عن
الخدمه بسبب تواجدها في منطقه الاشتباك
وحتى ذكرت انه رغم الهدنه حتى الان لازالت
خارجه عن العمل هل كان هناك في استهداف
مباشر
لاي من المرافق الصح او لا
لم نرصد وحتى كل الولايات وكانت عنايه
واضح اي
[موسيقى]
مؤسسه صحيه بعينه لكن للاسف الشديد يمكن
وجود بعض المؤسسات الصحيه ودي بيحتاج منها
الايه للمراجعه في المستقبل بعض كانت في
مرمى حجر من
الشيطان لان هي بتكون في منطقه الوسطى بين
الاثنين المتصارعين
كثير اذا كانت في وسط دارفور او في جنوب
دارفور
في مستشفياتنا حتى في الفاشر بنفس الطريقه
في شمال وعندنا في الخرطوم هنا المستشفيات
المركزيه برضه اكسرت لانها كانت في وسط
الخرطوم ومعها للاسف الشديد المستشفيات
الخاصه
بالانظف
وسؤال عن جد اخير هالمره ولكن لانه ذكرت
انت الارقام ضحايا هذه الاشتباكات حتى
الان في كافه المناطق
كونك ذكرت ايضا قبل قليل ان هناك صعوبه
بالوصول الى بعض المناطق هل نتوقع انه
الارقام
اكثر بكثير مما ذكر الان او لا
للاسف الشديد نتوقع ارقام لانه نحن نعرف
انه في جسامين موجوده خارجه خارج المؤسسات
الصحيه
وحتى الان في مناطق الصراع والناس ما
قادره تصل لها للاسف الشديد ممكن اذا كان
من قبل المدنيين او غيره
واكيد صار ما استمر الصراع نتوقع منه في
اصابات
للوحدات الصحيه اذا كان مراكز المستشفى
دكتور منتصر محمد عثمان مدير الاداره
العامه للطوارئ الصحيه ومكافحه الاوبئه في
وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه السودانيه شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات ونتمنى
السلامه لك ولكل الاطقم الطبيه
ومشاهدينا ننقل لكم هذه الصور وصلتنا قبل
قليل للاشتباكات في
في ولايه الابيض طبعا شمال كردفان طبعا
كردفان حاكم كردفان كان
قد خرج للحديث عن ما يحدث على الارض من
عمليات النهب وايضا اقتتال وكانت هناك
العديد من الصرخات التي تتخوف من ان تتسع
دائره الاشتباكات
لتطال احزاب مسلحه اخرى
حكوم الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
اولاد العوين جروا جروا
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
حقهم الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
مواجهه البرهان واحمد العسكريه بارض
المعركه يقابلها تنافس اعلامي لا يقل حده
وفي وقت اكد احمد عدم التراجع عن اهدافه
على اعتبار ان ارض المعركه ستحدد كل شيء
لفت البرهان الى خروج جزء كبير من قوات
احمدتي عن السيطره قائد قوه الدعم السريع
اعتبر ان البرهان ليس مستعدا للانتقال
للحكم المدني لكن الاخيره اكد استئناف
الانتقال للمسار الديمقراطي بمجرد هزيمه
احمدتي اهداف احمدتي تشمل اعتقال البرهان
ومحاكمته اهداف تبين محاوله الدعم السريع
الاستيلاء على السلطه وفق البرهان حملتي
شدد على عدم معارضه دمج قواته بالجيش من
حيث المبدا الجيش اكد الالتزام باستكمال
العمليه السياسيه وفق الاتفاق الايطالي
تراشق كلامي يستكمله بتاكيد انفتاحه على
وقف اعمال العطف لكنه يؤكد ايضا ان
البرهان لن يتوقف فيما يتهم قائد الجيش
قوه تحميتي باعمال نهب الخرطوم ودارفور
هذا هو نفث القوات المسلحه الليبيه بقياده
خليفه حفتر تقديم الدعم لطرف ضد الاخر من
طرفي الصراع الدائري في السودان المتحدث
باسم الجيش الوطني الليبي احمد المسماري
اوضح ان القوات المسلحه الليبيه تقوم
حاليا باجراء الاتصالات العاجله مع
الاطراف المعنيه مضيفا ان القياده مستعده
للقيام بدور الوساطه بين الاشقاء في
السودان لوقف القتال
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه العربيه
الليبيه تدعو وتناسب بذروت الوقوع الوقف
والفوري الاقتتال بين الاشقاء بدوله
السودان الشقيقه وعلى اهميه توفير الظروف
المناسبه للتهدئه وتغليب المصلحه الوطنيه
العليا وانتهاز هذه الايام المباركه بحلول
عيد الفطر المبارك لوقف كافه الاعمال
العسكريه وذلك للمساهمه في استعاده
استقرار الاوضاع بالبلاد عبر التواصل
والتنسيق بين جميع الاطراف بغيت ايجاد
الارضيه المشتركه للتوافق والخروج من
الازمه الحاليه وتداعياتها محليا واقليميا
ودوليا وفي هذا سدد فان القياده العامه
تنفي نفيا قاطعا ما تتناوله بعض وسائل
الاعلام الرخيصه
والمازوره بقيام القوات المسلحه العربيه
الليبيه تقديم الدعم لطرف ضد الطرف الاخر
بل نحن كنا وما زلنا وسنظل مع استقرار
دوله السودان وامنها وسلامتها وسلامه
شعبها العربي الافريقي الاصيل وتقوم حاليا
باجراء الاتصالات العاجله مع الاطراف
المعنيه وبيننا مستعدين للقيام بدور
الوساطه بين الاشقاف السودان لوقف القتال
فورا وفتح المجال للحوار بالطرق السلميه
المزيد اعود الى ضيفه من الخرطوم رئيس
التحرير صحيفه التغيير رشا عوض كيف
تتابعين هذا الموقف الليبي من حفتر طبعا
على لسان المسمار فيما يتعلق بالازمه
الراهنه ونفي اي تدخل
مرحبا مجددا بالمشاهدين وبكي
هذا الموقف يدل ان هذه الحرب حتى الان هي
محصوره في الاطراف الداخليه السودانيه
وليست لها حاضنه اقليميه
وهذا امر ايجابي لان ما نسعى اليه هو حجب
الاكسجين
هذه الطرف الحريق في اضيق
ونتمنى ان يعقل
طرفاء الحرب ويعلمون ان لا مكان في
السودان للانقلابات الاهليه للانقلابات
العسكريه ويجب ان لا يكون هناك مكان للحرب
الاهليه بين السودانيين التي لو استمرت
طويلا سوف تتحول الى حرب اقليميه
الامر كله رحيم لمالات القتال على الارض
ولما يفعله اطراف القتال لو استمروا
تكسير العظام
ومنطق
التحقيق انتصار نهائي وحاسم فان هذا بلا
شك في المحصله النهائيه سوف يوسع اعدادت
الحرب وسوف تكون هناك تدخلات اقليميه ولكن
التدخلات اقليميه وذكرت نقطه توسيع دائره
الحرب على المستوى الداخلي طبعا في دارفور
استمعنا الى حاكم دارفور يشتكي مما يحدث
من فوضى ونهب وقال ان كان الجيش لن يساعد
فسيتدخل وهذه ربما تكون صوره اخرى لشكل
التوسع التي يمكن ان يحدث هل يمكن بالفعل
ان تتوسع وماذا تعني مثل هذه التصريحات من
حاكم دارفور سيده رشا
طبعا هناك اطراف تريد لهذه الحرب ان تتحول
الى حرب اهليه شامله بين المكونات
الاجتماعيه في السودان
وطبعا السلب والنهب وهذه الاعمال هي اصلا
ترتبط باجواء الحرب وترتبط باجواء الفوضى
وكلما حدثت احداث لعب وشلب وترويع
للمواطنين سوف يتهم كل طرف بالاطراف الحرب
الطرف الاخر بانه تسبب فيها
وبالتالي طاحونه الحرب هي ستخرج كل
الشياطين في السودان وستحرق كل الوطن ولا
نستطيع التحقق على وجه الدقه من صحه
المعلومات المتداوله حول هويه من الذي
يذهب وهويه من الذي يسرقه ولكن هناك جانب
اخر هو ان نجتلب والنهب بعد اذا تطاول امد
الحرب
والطائقه التي يعيشها
السودانيون المجرمون العاديون سوف يقبلون
على النهب من اجل الاكل من اجل الطعام
والامر الملحوظ في هذه الحرب هو اختفاء
الشرطه وعدم قيامها
بواجبها في حمايه المواطنين سنتابع معك
طبعا في نشرات لاحقه من الخرطوم رئيس
التحرير صحيفه التغيير رشا عوض شكرا جزيلا
لك على المشاركه
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا الى موجز اخباري منفصل عما يجري
في السودان قام الامين العام لحلف شمال
الاطلسيه اول زياره له الى كيف منذ بدايه
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه واسعه النطاق
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه هذه الزياره جاءت
لتندرج ضمن مساء الحلف لمواصله دعم
اوكرانيا في الوقت الذي تستعد فيه لشن
هجوم مضاد قدم استلتم بريك خلال هذه
الزياره احترامه للجنود الاوكرانيين الذين
قتلوا اثناء القتال في الحرب وتم استعراض
المعدات العسكريه الروسيه التالفه في ساحه
مركزيه في كييف
بدوريه قال الرئيس الاوكراني ان الوقت قد
حان لدعوه كييف للانضمام الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي واتخاذ القرار المناسب شدد
زيلينسكي لدى لقائه ينس على ضروره ان تدعم
كل الدول المنخرطه في حلف الناتو انضمامها
اوكرانيا الى صفوفه
اعلنت ديمتري بريسكوف المتحدث باسم
الكرملين ان ترسنتين النوويتين لفرنسا
وبريطانيا هما تحت سيطره الولايات المتحده
ويجب تخفيضهما وقال بسكوب انهم اذا تحدثوا
للولايات المتحده دون مراعات هاتين
الترسانيتين لا معنى لها خاصه ان فرنسا
وبريطانيا نظام متكامل لحلف الناتو الخاضع
لسيطره الولايات المتحده
في فرنسا وعلى اثر رفع سن التقاعد
القانوني الى سن ال 64 عام تظاهر اكثر من
100 من عمال السكك الحديديه في محطه
للاحتجاج في مدينه ليون وطالبوا
المتظاهرين ضروره اصدار طلب المتظاهرون
ضروره اصدار قرار يتضمن اصلاح المعاشات
التقاعديه فضلا عن مطالبات طالت الرئيس
الفرنسي امان والماكرون بضروره تنحيه عن
منصبه الرئاسي في البلاد
شهدت ثلاثه مطارات في المانيا حاله من
الاضرابات من عناصر قوى الامن في مطارات
هامبرج وجزل وكولونيا وذكر بيان صادر من
الجمعيه الالمانيه للموانئ الجويه ان
الاضراب سينتج عنه الغاء حوالي 700 رحله
جويه في المطارات الثلاث خلال يومي الخميس
والجمعه مضيفه الى ان حوالي
45.2 الف مسافر اضطروا الى تغيير خططي
سفرهم
اوقفت الولايات المتحده بشكل كامل رحلات
طائراتها دون طيار من نوع جلوب الهوك
الاستراتيجيه فوق البحر الاسود بعد حادثه
تحطم طائره منتصف الشهر الجاري ووفقا
لبيانات صادره عن موقع فلاي رادار 24
فان الطائره الامريكيه من طراز جلوب الهوك
قامت باخر رحله فوق مياه البحر الاسود
قباله مارس الماضي ومنذ ذلك الحين لم تقم
الطائرات المسيره الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
الموجوده في قاعده تقليه بالدخول الى
المجال الجوي فوق البحر الاسود
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا التغطيه مستمره حول السودان على
راس الساعه مع الزميل خالد شكرا للمتابعه
مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا